well it is no secret travel and tourism
really took a big hit during the
pandemic so folks took
matters into their own hands started
buying rvs in motorhomes so they can
beat
all this cabin fever of the past year
safely eight news now reporter victoria
saha taking a look at what
rv dealerships have been seeing of late
rv sales have been skyrocketing here in
the valley
a major push has been the pandemic you
have everything you need
while you hit the road ron and peggy
conor child have been calling this rv
home for the past
month when we walked in the door we knew
we were home this
was the unit we were going to purchase
the retired couple had a house in
california for decades
but maintenance during the pandemic was
rough we're too old for that now
we want to enjoy life this is the best
thing that we
could really come up with vacations for
them meant always being on the road
now they get to do it full time as long
as we're healthy
we're going to do this their home on the
road has everything you need
a king sized bed a bathroom and a full
kitchen
the cannon childs aren't the only ones
with this mobile dream
at johnny walker rv they're selling rvs
as
quickly as they're getting them in
everybody's looking for new units used
units anything they can get their hands
on
in fact recent reports show the las
vegas metro area has the 20th
most rv sales definitely see an influx
of new buyers
and i think it's just because
everybody's appreciating the quality
time that they've been spending with
their family and they want to continue
it the dealership just sold about a
hundred units last month
whether you're looking for a small
trailer or a motor home
staff at johnny walker say they're here
ready to help you find your
next home away from home victoria saha
8 news now victoria thank you and
reports say rv dealers in the las vegas
metro area
generate annual sales of more than 250
million dollars